so when Bruce wayne/batman decides to
run Harvey Dent as the new District
Attorney Harvey Dent decides he will do
it but he doesn't in a disquieting way
he says this city needs a Caesar need
someone who's going to come in and clean
it up regardless of the law now I ask
you guys most of you are Americans what
happened to our country after 9/11 what
did we all feel when we saw those planes
go into those towers we gotta get those
guys no matter what it takes no matter
what laws have got a break we gotta get
those guys now I voted for President
Obama twice but President Obama sends
missiles to kill babies in the Middle
East every week why did we put up with
that if I could talk to him directly
what would he say to me he'd say Peter I
gotta do this yeah I know we're killing
innocent people but you want to be safe
don't you you don't want to know what we
have to do to keep you safe but we gotta
break the law guys this is why the dark
night is a brilliant story because
that's exactly what happens in this
story
Harvey Dent decides the evil is so bad
in the city that he's got to break the
law to do it so when he becomes powerful
as Batman's put him up here's what the
villain does the villain is so powerful
that he can walk into a group of
gangsters meeting and using a pin kill
one of their bodyguards and get away
with it and now the villains even more
powerful during a ceremony he has top
public officials killed and Harvey
didn't gets so angry at that that he
pulls one of the people aside one of the
villains cohorts and tortures him to get
information and when Batman shows up and
says you can't do it this way Harvey
you've got to obey the law you're part
of the law Harvey says but he's he's
evil and Batman says but he doesn't know
anything you're torturing him for no
reason he can't tell you what you want
to know so we already know and as we get
to the end of the first act that Harvey
Dent is unbalanced and even though he's
working for good his bravery has a
dangerous side to it and now here's
where
the villain really arranges Harvey Dent
he kidnaps Harvey Dent's fiancee Rachel
and he arranges for Harvey Dent to hear
her being tortured and killed with
gasoline now what would you do if your
fiance was raped or murdered or killed
while you watched how would you feel
would you be able to say let's let the
law take care of that I don't think I
could so Chris Nolan's brilliance is to
show that Harvey Dent is deranged by
this horrible evil and Harvey Dent
himself is burned in the same accident
burn badly but he now turns evil because
he is so angry
he begins to kill innocent people and as
he kills innocent people he becomes more
and more out of control until he finally
kidnaps the Commissioner of Police and
the family and is gonna shoot the child
in front of the Commissioner now here's
where the theme of our movie is really
important remember I talked about theme
a lot in University of story what's the
theme of this movie
and what's the BMOC the theme of this
movie is this and it's classic and it's
used in platoon it's used in many war
movies it's used over and over again
it's used in a story I'm working on
right now that we've created be careful
when you fight evil that you do not
become evil yourself that's the theme
you would say to President Bush to
President Obama to the American people
today because as a Hollywood liberal I
would say we have become evil in some
ways we're creating evil that's the
theme of Syriana that's a seam of many
social problem dramas and it's the theme
here of this great action movie be
careful when you fight evil that you do
not become evil yourself Batman is
forced to rescue the commissioners
family from Harvey Dent and as he does
so he must kill the person that he
brought in to bring justice and law to
the city and in the
I know great sophisticated ending of
this dark hero and a hero's story Batman
says to the Commissioner the people can
never know that Harvey Dent became
deranged I will become the sacrificial
goat they can blame me because the
people are not strong enough to know the
truth about how we fight evil this is
then exactly what President Obama would
tell me Peter you don't want to see
those pictures of those dead babies in
fact you can't go on google and see if
you can see them you won't because we
must be protected our leaders say by the
very tactics that we're used to keep us
safe today this is why a great action
movie can also be a great philosophical
movie and Dark Knight epitomizes this
third type of action hero the antihero
it's a brilliant story and it's a
brilliant story because it takes all the
great tools of action and puts it in
service of a great philosophical idea
which Chris Nolan always always does
you